77 all to 22 in this first pocket here
in the fourth quarter burner Murray
looks a MV a ruddy great timing first
game with this with his team and he puts
it right up on the rims and hammers down
to something like this because it's a
heck of a place to watch a game as sites
got rejected blank to the punch boy
Lorenzo Romar has amassed a lot of
talent there and the University of
Washington Murray an example of that if
Murray can't convert the old-fashioned
three-point play but even go to
Washington University with battling
bears division free champs in recent
years and all of a sudden Siobhan Saint
Marie like when I was over five at the
first half I better not let my team down
pretty kiss off the glass now buried
rubber pads
that's Lebanon through under the lathe
of a defender in play just on the
opposite side
Burton's was your last option number 45
coming across the floor Murray was your
first option as he fades now gets it
Murray the runner does have a timeout
before he came up to the top defender
cheated so he counters to the baseline
that's Wesley Johnson
I wish the Johnsons established player
pretty nice defender
there's Murray knock him down with
Crawford start this fall as well
[Music]
[Applause]
again knocks it down
Robi - had just been inconsistent even
though it's been a willing of group of
players as Murray it's the first basket
for San Antonio the posts check by Aminu
yields it outside this is Murray
floating and scoring out of three Murray
steals and outlet pass and laid it up
and in
here's Leonard against Farid degree back
to Jonte Murray in the paint
he's got natural instincts that it's
hard to teach both him he was the guy
who was tapping the ball keeping it
alive Murray
[Music]
top five league in steals gets another
one here green on the drives
Murray watches a train
[Applause]
first for the Spurs behind-the-back came
Italy lays it in how about that heads-up
play from the youngster he's not going
to challenge a bigger guy at the rim
Powell is back in the game with
Valanciunas Ross inside Valanciunas back
from behind Spurs the other way and
double figures without a player with 20
points Anderson picks the Denver
[Applause]
this long artist takes it away but
Murray and then beautiful pass right on
the money does not take Murray gets his
chance to show up Benton time for
Simmons then get off the ground on this
team took it to John days air pockets is
on the floor underneath Robinson misses
the dunk and Davis batons lost the
handle
Robinson blocked by Murray by down the
stretch but Indiana went on to lose six
straight legal nothing like that
how about the pass there from the
youngster so jaunty Murray nice little
crossover move there drops it off to
David Lee the exactly the right time
digging be able to impose his will at
the rim but it's the setup from the
point guard that gets him the bucket
behind Manu Ginobili and 45 ahead of
Sean Elliott David without the Murray
nice penetration of pitch once again
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
a crossover move the big fella time to
do China's best that that small forward
power cord position to stay in front of
the Jonte Murray to no avail to John
Payton to 42% so far
San Antonio 1 to 7 on their start
dismantling dassault goes down the
Murray did not alter the shotgun he
makes a nice water
I just want to triple and I'll be brown
they played at Cal State for left is all
by Murray to Dedmon high wire right
there by go in Devon it's Kawhi Leonard
missing he is filled that boy Anacin
poked away by Danny Green Marie Kyle
Anderson throws up and Murray throws it
down and it's back to 25 with two and I
have to play on the bird Oh innocent
Danny Green with the strip Laurie throws
ahead to Anderson the patience of an
inocent allowing Murray to get to the
cup Eric Gordon launches a three a
recently offensive boys goes back up
shot blocked by Murray and the rebound
the long arms of Murray
oh all 13 warriors of scourge biggie at
11 points in the first quarter the other
night Marie left-handed and the foul
this kid to play he's Johnson tell you
Lincoln Wayne Ellington elude the only
free agent of the bunch Forbes and open
it he's not afraid to step in the shots
he shot ready all the time
Whittington's readied on the weak side 1
until last year didn't lose again
and Marie with the steel punches at home
good to be there with ice and Big Dave
and Timmy that's a that's a dream
Felder's past taken away by the John Jay
Murray to Danny Green and Danny stores
start things off their 2018 read the
three points we have to be number one
year ago John Taylor II that's a great
style and get him scoring her you're his
hurry up front driving awkward run the
dunk and a great move into Jonte action
his season-high now that he's got 20
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
every day to be on the phone
Green puts a soft pass right on the
money the desert is there to devour that
one water beautiful finish six guys in
double figures led by Pau Gasol
double-double with 21 and 10 rudy Gay
fell dirt trying to get it away from him
oh that John James Murray the defense
here Felger thought he had the chance to
take it there but they starts dancing on
the defense Crawford with it out front
[Music]
look for the steal oh and then Murray
with the block I believe when the Spurs
come right back
[Music]
Alvin in his third year here and Murray
tosses this one little I got the tire
out there cardio and endurance and just
getting in more basketball shape Murray
Bastille in a bucket how about that over
from the dog game over his career Murray
it's Westbrook for the job Dave Murray
up Obama what a play against the
reigning MVP he climbs the glass first
tenth rebound bring it into the break
white Murray in the pace that he scores
oh mama Houston Rockets and this team
has been especially good where the
Houston community is Laverne punches at
what when you think about the
devastation in the Houston area Chris
Paul and Harden done for the night
that's going to be an n1 for Murray
[Applause]
we saw the first couple weeks of the
season absorbs the contact there take
over here most of the drop swings it to
the John team
[Applause]
ooh slick passes by the way the first
one the palace all got a block and he
comes back and he's got another one
they're in stores if the first one
doesn't succeed try again
ruining with two spec passes only one
assist but you got to love the effort
and then dijanna the shot at the top of
the glass clean up walk by Murray out of
bounds there is and do in like that
little floater penetrating left in his
right hand then he comes back burner
bills coming for the steel underneath
shot hole Oh
Jonte Murray knocking it away good help
defense from Murray third near in Fox
blocked by Murray on the deck Thomas has
got at the outlet Patty Mills racing the
ball up scores important border
gets it right back and
all the way up to the layer for Verizon
gave him that great blood and gun
offense they had when they were fighting
Murray with a dunk and Laverne again
finding him the lead out to Murray the
two-hand dunk the shot take it's a
chance to show off his athleticism that
right now is carrying over gotta take a
better entry town
great job created opportunity players
only football movie there's they're just
too crowded on that side before to too
much time and still make lemonade out of
it I guess Bono's to Dallas swings it
back out Murray
oh good muscle there that just imposes
puts it off the window
how about blowing their shoulder into
George Hill some good look at clean
Schneider their head coaches Anderson
comes up with the steal the lead out
[Applause]
James inside
tonight's entice been blocked from
behind by Murray and the shot clock
expires
good defense by San Antonio I'm at the
clock Don see with Gasol jumping back
and forth he had to get them on that
roach it needs to be said to create
change meaningful change in his
community and beyond Murray with the
steal - Rudy gay and gay with the
late-night you see the bench
the reason the Spurs had the lead in
this one 31 16
[Applause]
the second half of a ball game right
there Kyle Anderson wanted to throw the
bounce pass the defense was anticipated
to microclean lucky may have jumped up
very fond of nice offense by the defense
go to college
[Applause]
warriors take a timeout who's just
offered that knowing I wouldn't be able
to take advantage by the end of your
career you can just go here carry the
[Applause]
[Music]
ball down beautiful steel there from the
Jonte he's not gonna have a chance to
dump it so just make sure you get the
two in the open court does he got that
ball spotting green corner three could
have easily taken that but our guys off
to the races
bhishan to the kyle back to the John
Tate Murray with a steal that pass from
cook Murray drives inside throws it down
timeout Golden State like Reese
Witherspoon and Legally Blonde dogs
you're up on that movie huh
Murray ladies it impulsive foul well
they are just getting at it
[Applause]
Jake's victory a big game against OKC on
the road as he tries to get by carousing
dishes to Anderson for the slam but
Murrieta game six points seven rebounds
8 assists MERS here in the passing game
people look to the left side you're
gonna see ah there he comes he came from
that left corner Rosco Oh a lot of
contact Aldrich and the push the Jonte
on the spot so what but he is an
excellent rebounder for a god
[Applause]
what here comes Danny Green back with it
nine road playoff games Reggie getting
back the last season here's a steal
Murray the other way Jane Murray with
the steal here pickpocket Wayne cook and
the finish he's got a seven-foot arm
span never won a series down three games
to none and the other way Murray with a
couple seconds left in Golden State will
get this one in San Antonio tonight
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content